- I hear that your mom
has a few famous admirers
which I love this.
- [Topher] This is a true story.
- And I've never seen
your mom and I'm like,
I gotta check out your mom.
- My mom is a good looking woman.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Shout out to Pat Grace.
- [Kelly] Yes.
- And uh, she, this happened
when I did this film
"In Good Company" with Dennis Quaid.
I couldn't' believe that I
was like starring in a movie
with Dennis Quaid.
And she came to set with my dad.
And Dennis was very nice to them.
It was huge star and
they couldn't believe it.
And then as he was walking
away, he was really nice.
He said to me like, oh your mom's cute.
And my mom overheard it.
And sadly my dad overheard it too.
And it was like a real bummer for them.
But like she was, I mean
she really took it to heart.
- [Kelly] That's so nice.
- And yeah, and then when
I went to the premiere
of that movie, I was waiting
in the lobby of a hotel.
I was meeting my mom
there and she was late.
She was with my dad, but she
was getting her hair done
'cause she was gonna see Dennis again.
(laughing)
And she um--
- Your dad is like, I hate this guy.
- Yeah my dad was like not
looking forward to the premiere.
But she um, I was there in
the bar and I saw Liam Neeson
who's always you know, great--
- Love Liam Neeson.
- [Topher] Great, attractive--
- Yes.
- Other big star.
And uh, he said why are you
waiting here for your parents?
And I told him this whole story.
And then I said, just get out of here,
you don't want to meet them.
And he said, no I'd love
to meet your parents.
So they came in and, Liam Neeson,
I've never seen him again,
but I think this is the
funniest thing ever.
He goes, uh, Patricia it's
so lovely to meet you.
Dennis Quaid told me you were cute,
but he didn't do you justice.
(laughing)
- Oh my gosh.
- And she like passed out.
She couldn't believe what was going on.
- I would've died.
He's one of my favorite people ever.
- And my dad was like, oh what the hell.
- Your dad was like, are you serious?
Come on.
He was like...
That's amazing though,
she must've felt so good.
- She worked at a private
school at the time
and I think she was back
at the school saying,
oh no, now I'm causing
this rift between...
- Dennis Quaid and Liam Neeson.
- Dennis and Liam
and like I just shouldn't
even go out there anymore.
- Like, boys.
I love it, I wanna meet her.